hey 42 here let's take a look at what's
going on in Syria many North African and
Middle Eastern countries are ruled by an
iron fist governments that pretend to be
democracies but displays strong
dictatorship qualities and oppress
change in recent years there has been a
sudden influx of mass demonstrations in
these Arab countries attempting to
overthrow their corrupt rulers it's
called the Arab Spring and it was all
started in Tunisia in 2010 by a single
fruit and vegetable seller named Mohamed
Bouazizi
after he set himself on fire in protest
of the government the Tunisian
Revolution subsequently inspired other
Arab nations across North Africa and the
Middle East to protest notably Egypt
Syria is the latest to jump on the
revolutionary bandwagon Syria has been
ruled by the same Syrian family the
Assad's since 1971 their political party
is the Baath Party the current Syrian
President Bashar al-assad has been in
power since 2000 in the last referendum
in 2007 Bashar al-assad was the only
candidate securing his presidency for
another seven-year term seemed fair sick
of the Assad's tight regime on the 15th
of March 2011 Syrian civilians started
their own Arab Spring protests which
quickly gained momentum and devolved
into the Syrian civil war in July 2011
the Free Syrian Army was formed an
umbrella group representing the Syrian
rebels in April 2011 the Syrian
government's army was deployed to stop
the uprising in its tracks
soldiers fired on demonstrators in towns
and cities across the country
after months of military siege the
protesters got their hands on weapons of
their own and started a full-scale armed
rebellion consisting of defected
soldiers and civilian volunteers Syrian
allies Russia and Iran supply the
government with weapons whilst Qatar and
Saudi Arabia provide the rebels with
their weaponry the death toll has now
surpassed a hundred thousand half of
which are civilians including both
rebels and innocent bystanders the over
half our Syrian Army soldiers under
thousand government officials 1.8
million Syrians have fled the country to
escape the violence tens of thousands of
protesters have been imprisoned and
there are widespread reports of torture
in the nation's prisons the Syrian
government and protesters have both been
accused of severe human rights abuse
however the United Nations
investigations have concluded that the
Syrian government's human rights abuse
has been far greater but the rebels
aren't exactly Saints either certain
Sevilla noble groups have pledged
loyalty to al-qaeda and beheaded
numerous Christians in January 2012 the
Syrian army started to use large-scale
artillery and tanks against a rebel army
which led to many civilian homes being
destroyed because of indiscriminate
shelling by July 2012 the fighting had
spread across the whole country and the
International Committee of the Red Cross
declared the conflict a civil war the
fighting focused on Syria's capital city
Damascus by late July the government
managed to push back the rebel forces in
Damascus and the focus of the war
shifted to the city of Aleppo a year
later and the bulk of the Syrian civil
war still revolves around Aleppo so
what's the latest news on the Syrian
conflict
well the rebels and Western governments
have accused the Syrian government of
using chemical weapons in attacks that
killed more than 1429 people near
Damascus 426 of which were children one
of the bombs was dropped onto a school
playground the use of chemical weapons
is strictly outlawed by international
law the Syrian government has said the
rebels were behind the chemical attacks
however according to the US government
the rockets were only launched from
government controlled areas and only
aimed towards opposition controlled
areas on the 30th of August British
Prime Minister David Cameron was
defeated in the House of Commons in a
vote to join the u.s. in strikes against
Syria in order to deter the use of
chemical weapons
therefore Britain will not be involved
in any military action in Syria
the u.s. is a bit miffed of this
decision but they have said they will
continue to consult with the UK one of
their closest allies Obama has said the
US will be responding to the use of
chemical weapons in Syria what he stated
there will be no quoting quote boots on
the ground in other words many skeptics
are against the use of military action
in Syria fearing it may be a repeat of a
rat 60% of the United States public says
the US government should not take
military action against Syria many fear
such an attack could lead to World War 3
Syria has said it will use quoting quote
all means available to defend itself if
the United States attacks which could
include terror attacks in the u.s.
itself Russia have sent their most
advanced anti-ship missiles to Syria if
one of those sinks the US vessel it
would sure to escalate matters to a
whole new level there is a very good
chance that if the u.s. attacks Syria
Syria will attack Israel Israel have
said it would respond to any attack
forcefully which would surely spell
disaster Iran's closest ally is Syria
and around aren't going to say likely to
any attack against Syria furthermore an
attack against Syria will seriously
damage the United States relationship
with Russia all of these factors and
more could easily contribute to the
start of the next world war really hope
you've enjoyed this video let me know in
the comments below if you'd like me to
do more of these videos related to
current affairs such as this thanks for
watching until next time